[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben da ich immer wieder die
frage bekomme ob ich nicht ein bisschen
mehr fingerfood auf meinem kanal zeigen
kann habe ich mir für euch diese
würzigen schnecken mit hackfleisch
überlegt als basis für die schnecken
benötigen wir einmal meinen pizza grund
teig das video dazu habe ich schon auf
youtube gepostet dass verlinke ich euch
in die infobox den habe ich einmal
zubereitet desweiteren benötigen wir
hackfleisch ich habe hier mageres
rinderhack genommen etwas tomatenmark an
gewürzen salz pfeffer edel süßes
paprikapulver und oregano knoblauch
zwiebeln ich habe hier rote genommen
außerdem noch gouda käse und geröstetem
sesam ein eigelb mit etwas milch
verquirlt für die optik
als erstes wird das öl in der pfanne
erhitzt und die knoblauchzehen darin
angedünstet
[Musik]
anschließend wird das hackfleisch mit
dazu gegeben und angebraten
[Musik]
nachdem das hackfleisch im topf gebraten
wurde geben wir das tomatenmark mit
hinein
sobald das schön eingearbeitet ist
kommen die gewürze mit dazu und werden
gut unter gemengt
das hackfleisch kann jetzt erst mal kurz
an die seite gestellt werden und wir
machen weiter mit unserem pizzateig den
habe ich schön aufgehen lassen und
nehmen jetzt erstmal aus der schüssel
nun noch mal ganz kurz durchkneten und
anschließend rechteckig ausbreiten
[Musik]
den teig habe ich dann relativ dünn
ausgerollt er hatte am ende ungefähr die
größe eines backblech und an der stelle
noch ein kleiner tipp wer es mal einig
hat der kann auch fertigen blätterteig
nehmen oder ausnahmsweise auch fertigen
pizzateig selbstgemachter schmeckt aber
wesentlich besser
[Musik]
auf den teig geben wir nun zu allererst
unseren käse
[Musik]
auf den käse geben wir jetzt die
komplette hackfleisch füllung und
verteilen sie gleichmäßig
[Musik]
darüber kommen dann die zwiebeln wer
also kein zwiebel fan ist der kann sie
an der stelle auch einfach weglassen ihr
könnt auch gerne zutaten hinzufügen wie
zum beispiel mais oder erbsen je nachdem
was sie am liebsten mögt und sobald ihr
auch die zwiebeln verteilt habt gebt ihr
noch eine zweite schicht käse drauf
ihr seht dass sich die füllung nicht bis
zum rand verteilt habe denn dann können
wir garantieren dass uns nichts von der
füllung rausfällt jetzt können wir das
ganze von unten nach oben schön
aufrollen
sobald er den teig komplett aufgerollt
habt gebt sie ihn auf euer schneidebrett
und dann schneiden wir uns ca zwei bis
zweieinhalb breite scheiben ab
[Musik]
und so könnt ihr dann weitermachen bis
ihr die komplette teigrolle
durchgeschnitten habt
[Musik]
nachdem ihr sie dann auf ein backblech
platziert habt bestreichen wir das ganze
noch mit einer mischung aus eigelb und
etwas milch damit sie auch eine schöne
farbe bekommen
ich bestreite ich hier an den seiten und
hinterher auch noch an der oberfläche
und wenn ihr den schritt auch getan habt
dann müsst ihr nur noch den juristen
sesam darüber geben und dann kann das
ganze auch schon in den backofen
dort kommen sie bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für 20 bis 25 minuten rein
und wenn sie schön gebräunt sind dann
sind sie auch schon fertig und können
sofort serviert werden
von innen sind die schön fluffig und von
außen knusprig und probiert sie doch
gerne mal aus sehr wird sie mit eurem
lieblings tipp und dann kann eurer party
nichts mehr im wege steht
die genauen mengenangaben stehen wie
immer unten in der infobox ich freue
mich sehr auf euer feedback und sagt bis
zum nächsten mal auf die skizzen